salut bienvenue dans cette vidéo vous
avez compris on va rencontrer bernard
tellier l'ancien négociateur du gign
j'ai eu la chance de travailler avec lui
récemment en fait en début d'année on a
créé un programme pour la télévision que
j'ai produit qui sera diffusé sur tmc on
n'a pas la date de diffusion on aurait
dû de l'avoir pour cette vidéo on ne l'a
pas donc vous savez quoi je l'annoncerai
sur mon instagram dès que je les ai
peut-être ne me fera un live pendant la
diffusion donc ça je sais pas si je
pourrai vous en reparler sur youtube en
tout cas sur instagram je vous en
parlerai c'est sûr et donc à l'occasion
de ce tournage on a énormément discuté
on a évidemment énormément de points
communs dans nos centres d'intérêts sur
la psychologie le mentalisme le cerveau
etc et on a décidé de créer cette petite
discussion pour parler de ce qu'il a
vécu hui en tant que négociateur du gign
genre sa première intervention allaient
déjà vous allez la découvrir parce que
c'est tout l'intérêt de la vidéo posez
vous écoutez l'expérience de ce gars
savent y aller incroyable les parallèles
avec le mentalisme ils sont dingues
merci à lui cette pré telle expérience
merci à vous de regarder la vidéo merci
à la vie d'êtres la vie dans la première
question et à les garder assez basique
c'est une question de parcours par
exemple tu as fait quoi toi comme
étudiante à 26,6 et un deuil de psy que
tu fais un dock d'opci un moment donné
qu est-ce qui fait qu'entre octobre six
négociateurs du gign c'est quoi le pont
qui se forment c'est des hasards c'est
une volonté c'est mon père était
gendarme qui a une influence mais même
si on ne peut pas l'admettre il ya quand
même une influence donc j'étais tribales
et de pis en pis continent continent par
le métier mon père a fait 4 en algérie
on avait 8 ans berlin est chargé en
france j'avais à peu près 14 ans mais
j'adorais cette recette vie où il y
avait vraiment une cohésion entre les
gendarmes tout ça qu'il veut en caserne
et je me suis dit pourquoi pas la
gendarmerie mais quitte à rentrer dans
la gendarmerie je rentrais au jijel le
problème c'est que toucher sur quatre
ans en gendarmerie avant de passer les
tests au kef donc si tu loupes les
thèses mata quatre ans
c'est quoi ces tests psychologiques
physiques culture est ce que c'est
physique c'est vrai ça une base physique
mais on va prendre les plus forts
psychologiquement on entend prendre des
plus forts physiquement parce que les
muscles chez nous ça sert pas à grand
chose imagine tu es devant une porte
avec tact et russes qui s'attend on à
l'intérieur il ya certaines unités qui
prennent des béni pour casser les portes
vont m'aider de l'explosion n'est milité
en faveur de l'expo donc la porte
s'ouvre tout seul et tes premiers à
entrer et là tu te retrouve nez à nez
avec trois quatre terroristes ou des
forcenés des preneurs d'otages tu
comprends les muscles ça ne sert à rien
c'est psychologique il faut avoir le
courage de passer cette porte est donc
on va prendre les gens qui sont plus
forts psychologiquement et pas plus
forcément plus fort physiquement
peut-être peut-être ses secrets mais tu
peux donner un exemple de tests
psychologiques en taper passé ou alors
c'est même pas des tests et en fin de
compte on met en état de fatigue intense
et 14 mois à peu près enfin c'est
beaucoup plus d'un an va enfin moi j'ai
vu des gens qui étaient incroyablement
fort et dès qu'ils étaient fatigués se
mettait en colère après les autres
stagiaires donc on comprend on n'a pas
besoin on n'a pas besoin de quelqu'un
comme ça aux indigènes énergie dans une
colonne d'assaut parce que sa démission
durée de trois jours et démons ben s'il
y en a qui nous fait un boulot dans la
colonne d'assaut c'est un peut pas donc
on préfère des gens qui sont stables et
et on a remarqué que je n'ai pas
forcément les plus physiques étaient les
plus stables et intègre le gign est
directement tu rentres dans le côté une
négociation pour faire nombre chantre
oxygène pour faire 21 mois c'était
vraiment le terme et c'est ma première
mission s'était ceci breveté et quelques
heures après une mission on arrive on à
aller on a entre 5 et 10 minutes pour
arriver au gign fixé à 14 heures à 2
heures du matin peu importe à 5 minutes
10 minutes par idéologie jeunes et dans
la demi-heure faut être partie qui peut
être parti en afghanistan mali ou sur
paris une alerte sonne j'arrive aux
gènes et on part c'est en bretagne sur 1
une prise d'otage nous a vendu des rêves
on peut aller n'importe où dans le monde
on va en bretagne à plougastel manger
des fraises vous lie la bretagne
et là on tombe sur un gars qui avait tué
énormément de monde et mon cher le
groupe dit bernard tu passes première
colonne berceau de baptême du feu c'est
ma première mission premier la colonne
d'assaut il ya au moins un qui franchira
l'apport voilà huit cadavres qui sont un
peu partout des chemins des civils et là
le négociateur commence à faire la
négociation moi je mets en position tu
as quand même 20 kg surtout rhin
d'équipement et puis 1h 2h 5h et 8h 10h
négociations et au bout de dix heures il
a réussi à l'amener en bas et la france
dans le top action je tourne devant la
porte je tombe nez à nez comme toi en
face de lui l'un son fusil il montre le
fusil j'attrape leur usine le coup il
part dans le mur je le fais tomber allez
une demi seconde intervention pour 8
heures d'attentes et la jeunesse
peut-être je me suis trompé et peut-être
que le négociateur c'est pas mal aussi
alors avant j'ai fait juste europe le
shit europe c'est on est largué par
avion avec un parachute parce que sinon
le fait qu'une fois
à la gtc
vous mettre un parachute et donc on en
est pour par exemple des démissions à
l'étranger pour l'arrestation de
criminels de guerre on peut être
parachuté dans des pays étrangers et
c'est pas acheté à maubeuge du coup là
mais on allait aussi à maubeuge et bien
un para club à maubeuge âge donc on a
les emplois cette année c'était en effet
une dizaine de chutes europe et il n'y
avait pas de place pour la négo la
première année et la deuxième année une
place donc je me suis présenté des tests
en interne j'étais retenu et j'ai fait
deux ans de formation en interne ce
n'est pas maintenant alors ce qui est
bien c'est que c'est une formation
active c'est à dire que dès les premiers
cours tu déconnes mission tu pars avec
un négociateur confirmé enquêter en
second plan dès qu'ils voient à mettre
en place va négocier tu vois peu du coup
il ya il ya plusieurs négociateurs comme
ça il ya des passages de relais aussi
normal soit que le premier comment a
commencé à négocier on le laisse parce
que déjà on essaye de prendre notre
couverture que négociateur du gign pas
ce que ça peu stressé notre preneurs
d'otages
parce qu'imaginez c'est à tout tout de
suite regardé les films américains tu
vois là que l'équipe d'assaut des
tireurs d'élite lennar mal négocié et
donc la personne se sent un peu piégé
donc on évite de le stresser on va
prendre une autre couverture on peut
prendre un match déjà pris médecins
infirmiers il ne faut pas en faut pas
qu'on le mette en plus est déjà en mode
défensif donc il faut pas qu'on le camp
le stress en cooperation c'est alors ça
c'est passionnant donc c'est comme ça
que tu arrives en négociateur
meknes couture
en tant que négociateur tu as une
opération difficile qui t'a marqué que
tu pourrais nous raconter quelque chose
à te dis voilà là ça symbolise bien
d'eux s'est pas jouée d'avancé alors
ouais mais je vais faire pleurer tout le
monde on t'écoute alors attention si
vous n'aimez pas pleurer passé ce
passage on nous appelle on est vraiment
la dernière roue du carrosse il ya des
gens qu'on s'y négocie avant nous sap a
marché privé se disent mince mis à mort
et on appelle le jdj donc on arrivait
souvent malheureusement déjà des morts
et c'était pour un père de famille qu'il
est en otage ses deux enfants et quand
j'arrive genre d'un coup de feu il tue
son premier enfant et ils végètent le
corps sur le palier je sais pas si tu
connais le phénomène phénoménologie
c'est à dire oui voir les choses telles
qu'elles apparaissent vraiment lutté et
et sait se battre contre son éducation
ce n'est pas contre ces préjugés
exactement et c'est pour savoir vraiment
fait recette par deux choses mais parce
que si là tu te dit ce mec là c'est
monstrueux c'est un monstre toi même tu
rates déjà la négociation tout à fait en
plus tout le monde dit que c'est un
monstre mais quand on interroge les
familles des otages le préfet il me dit
moi j'ai négocié avec 3h ou 4h avec qui
mais pas des prochains mois s'annoncent
au bout de 90 de son enfance en parler
et donc dans ces cas là
tu sais et ça c'est partout pareil les
gens vont retenir plus tes défauts que
de qualités ben on va te juger par
rapport à tes points faibles et là dans
une prise d'otages le preneur d'otages
est toujours jugée par rapport à ce
qu'il vient de leurs feux de fait de
faire et jamais par rapport à sa vie
entière et moi mon objectif c'est de
comprendre sa vie comprendre le passé
pour pouvoir parler maintenant et c'est
pas me juger sur ce qu'il a fait
maintenant si je juge qu'il a fait
maintenant marre et je me fais un pas
que le condamne merci à exactement d'un
tout de suite et en plus à l'époque
j'avais j'ai des jumelles
pas comme ça parce que pour dire au juge
n voilà 91 guillemette des filles est
calé quatre ans à peu près autant qu'en
plus tu peut projeter transférer ses
supérieurs et donc mon objectif est de
me fit un objectif et m'a dit maintenant
tu vas devoir sauver le l'autre garçon
de 8 ans et si tu peux le faire aussi si
tu y arrives pas mal et légumes dassault
où on en sera la somme et la sauce est
toujours là un gros moyens risque quand
te donne un objectif c'est super dur
parce que tu as très peu de temps pour
trouver neutre à une stratégie pour
atteindre cet objectif et en plus c'est
une tension énorme tas toujours peur
qu'une deuxième enfant tu as toujours
peur que le préfet robien épique et u10
non lancé un assaut j'ai changé d'avis
et c est donc tu travailles sur quelque
chose de très intensifs est ce que j'ai
remarqué en généralement l'émission le
plus dangereux c'est pas le risque le
risque selon le communiqué james et la
mort le plus dangereux c'est toujours
l'incertitude l'incertitude de la
mission est ce qu'il va me parler est ce
qui va libérer son deuxième enfant et là
tu cogites eu pose plein de questions
nous risquons se prépare on a des gilets
pare-balles ont des entraînements et
saint flour mais cette incertitude c'est
vraiment extrêmement long et incertain
le groupe minier top négo rivasi donc
c'est un couloir et c'est un bâtiment et
je suis dans le couloir donc à l'abri
même si c'est un coureur avec un rôle
quand tu négocies excuse moi j'ai
l'image des films en tête il s'agit pas
de faire un truc à distance forcément
par téléphone ça peut être à proximité
de la personne en fait alors
pratiquement jamais fait par téléphone
hockey pratiqué par imerys les gars qui
sont là tu t'imagines et toi que c'était
2 si près
j'ai d'expliquer pourquoi moi quand
j'arrive sur une mission la première
chose que je faisais peu importe la
prise d'otages et jallet jusqu'à la
porte du preneur d'otages sans qu'ils
savent que chaud là j'ai jusqu'à sa
porte ok pourquoi ton avis pourquoi tu
aller jusqu'à sa mort en retrait pour
voir si surveille et comment réagit non
pour écouter ce qui se passe derrière
pour écouter quoi écouter oui mais quoi
écoutez combien ils sont écouter ce qui
se dit les écouter les menaces écouter
des émotions ah oui d'elle parce que je
peux t'assurer que quand j'entendais les
otages pleurer quand j'entendais la peur
des autres achats se ressemblent par les
sanglots des otages puis quand
j'entendais la couleur du preneur
d'otages également que j'allais me
défoncer pour eux si je restais dans un
bureau à cinq kilomètres je savais que
c'était une prise je savais que c'était
dangereux mais je n'allais pas me
synchronisée émotionnellement avec hélas
déjà j'avais changé et à partir de là je
voulais plus à perdre et donc j'y
arrivais le chef de groupe il avait
commencé anigo et là je me mets comment
je vais faire le préfère parler pendant
quatre heures avec lui il ya pas
décrocher un mot et au bout de quatre
heures et tu son enfant si je parle
qu'est ce qu'il va faire ce qu'il va
tuer son épouse et mes enfants ça et là
j'ai une idée comme ça et on va dire que
c'est monsieur durand je l'appelle chez
monsieur durand je m'appelle perdre
intéligent du médecin et je ne veux pas
laisser arnaud arnaud c'est le dit 88
sur le palier et je vais me chercher
donc ça maurice parce que là je suis
obligé de prendre la pole mais avant
j'ai écouté à la porte les émotions et
je peux t'assurer qu'il ait beaucoup
d'amour entre le deuxième garçon de 8
ans et le papa il papa et le petit avait
il y avait vraiment beaucoup d'amour je
les entendais parler qui leur assurerait
tout ça incroyablement bizarre qu'il ait
tué son enfant et qui est beaucoup
d'amour m et donc
je vais chercher ce petit je prends dans
mes bras et là ça me rend extrêmement
dur ce petit corps dans les bras là et
j'ai peur aussi qui me taire parce que
la porte avait juste là et je sers ce
petit corps dans mes bras de peur
peut-être aussi et à son fonds qui vont
me rappellerai toute ma vie sans fond de
ton dans mon cou et la chanson souffrons
tous froid tu seras et je me retourne et
j'arrive heures je recule 4 temps que
j'arrive dans leur coin pour plus être
menacé par un tir 6 tirs et là ce coup
je me retournais chez toute l'équipe
d'assaut cayla et je vois que j'ai les
influencent négativement forcément je
mène ce petit arnaud dans le chai des
pompiers et le médecin des pompiers me
dit alors ils s'affairent autour d'eux
mais il me dit c'est trop tard il est
mort je vous savez bien mais j'ai besoin
de l'entendre aussi je retourne dans
leur le d'escalier et puis je rappelle
monsieur durand et je lui dis ça y est
j'ai déposé arnaud dans le camion des
pompiers et là j'entends des à la porte
merci ça fait trois minutes que je sais
que j'ai négocié avec lui ça y est il a
commencé à me parler et l'empathie ça se
donne ça ce n'est pas de mots pour
redonner empâté il s'est vraiment
l'empathie sa sologne à des gestes qui
font ça et d'avoir fait ce geste là ça
complètement tout débloquer en fin de
compte c'était incertaine un suicide
altruiste c'est à dire que ces enfants
étaient malheureux et c'est vrai que
c'était extrêmement malheureux ces
petits le monde c'était la maman s'était
pas mis et dans un élan d'amour pour que
ces enfants arrêtent de souffrir en
études je mets bien mauvais repart tous
les caprices le peu de souffrance voilà
on nous dit mais vous avez des tireurs
d'élite qui sont capables de tirer
jusqu'à un kilomètre 5 pourquoi vous ne
remettez pas une balle dans la tête a ce
qu'il mérite pas de mourir et tu sais
dans beaucoup de mes négociations je me
suis dit si j'avais leur parcours de vie
ma chemise col fait mes choix tant mieux
que ouais j'aurais peut-être et la même
chose que la question suivante alors que
c'est que c'est quoi les causes
psychologiques que tu tires ou utilisent
le plus pour négocier est ce que tu as
consacré avec plein de technique et à
quelques techniques de prédilection tu
parlais déjà de l'empathie déjà de
montrer de l'empathie mais il faut
avoir une certaine sensibilité on
communique avec nos sens nos sensations
donc cette sensibilité à sensibilité est
très important quelqu'un qui n'est pas
sensible ne pourra pas être un bon
négociateur il va peut-être appliquer
des techniques mais comme face à voir
mais très technique au bon moment est ce
que ça sert à strictement rien par
contre associant faut la maîtriser cette
sensibilité parce que tu te fies tu
passe vite de l'empathie à la sympathie
et là c'est terminé pour toi il faut
rester dans l'empathie la différence
entre les deux l'empathie c'est
comprendre les émotions des autres la
sympathie c'est on va faire souffrir
avec mais le problème c'est que tu si tu
tombes en sympathie avec mon preneurs
d'otages ça se passe comme ce papa et
ben tu as pu être objectif tu allais
pardonner beaucoup de choses tu vas pas
savoir lui dire non et là c'est
catastrophique donc moi je restais
toujours dans l'empathie mais je faisais
tout pour que l'autre bascule dans la
sympathique et là à partir de la main
c'était nickel et plus de mal à voir me
dire non et puis surtout il allait avoir
du mal à me contredire il a une part
donné beaucoup de choses si je faisais
on fait des petites erreurs c'est à dire
c'est comme ça qu'on progresse il me
parlait plus les petites erreurs c'est
un peu dur que ce que je vais dire mais
la libération d'otages c'est un acte de
vente la tablette techniques et les
tactiques c'est 80 pour son empathie et
20% technique mais si tu fais que de
l'empathie boîte à 80% de rien et si tu
fais que des techniques tel un poisson à
rien donc c'est vraiment un mélange et 2
et moi j'appelle ça de psycho ciation
c'est pas la psychologie c'est pas de la
négociation c'est vraiment un mélange et
deux noirs oui il ya des techniques
l'étiquetage émotionnel ces choses là on
les connaît et c'est la synchronisation
garde naturellement par nature et des
mains trois étoiles auront désormais
deux positions c'est ça je désire me
refais comme toi
non mais c'est ça c'est ça en fait ça
pour s'écouter pour se comprendre les
outils c'est pas c'est pas 70% du truc
c'est beaucoup plus faible que ça
peut-être que ça va permettre d'enfoncer
le clou d'aller bien sûr la direction de
ce que je peux faire la différence et
voilà et je suis sûr que en parler tu
donne aussi des conférences pour les
entreprises on peut te faire venir en
conférence est et même à l'intérieur de
ça je suis sûr que tu as dû réguler un
petit peu ta négociations avec le public
des salles publiques de conférences et
des gens à qui en ligne à une conférence
soit allé la voir c'est la société qui
met en place faire la négociation de je
vous assure que vous êtes au bon endroit
même là tu as dû ressentir jeu enfin là
c'est une question que je me pose mais
ouais t'as dû mettre cet apport
empathique à la foule aussi ajouté
coûtent etc les gens me disent souvent
mais ça doit être fade la vie après jim
gène machine on s'est pas fait du tout
si on sait bien se reconvertir ses
parades ils me disent mais vous avez pu
l'adrénaline merci si je les
l'adrénaline alors je leur dis un truc
tout simple je dis vous préféré être
devant un client qui vous parle mal ou
devant un gresini qui vous foncent
dessus vous êtes au canada et un
physique qui me font dessus bas devant
le client pourquoi parce qu'on risque
pas de mourir ok mais le stress est une
réaction psychologique et physiologique
vous savez que vous risquez pas de
mourir mais votre corps ne sais pas si
il sait quelque chose qui va pas et dans
le doute ils ont retenu les analystes à
des gens qui tremble exactement moi
quand je suis une conférence devant vous
eh bien c'est la même chose je suis là
dans les coulisses j'attends je vous
entends on m'appelle mon corps c'est
parce que s'ils suent toujours en
intervention si je suis en confiance
donc je retrouve mon ami je retrouve ma
concentration que j'avais exactement
quand jade en mission c'est exactement
la même chose pour le cerveau il n'y a
pas de différence la peur est la peur le
stress et le stress et il envoie tout il
sait pas d'oser quoi c'est quoi la plus
longue intervention sur laquelle tu est
intervenue trois jours trois jours de
négociation c'était un bon melon dans
l'est de la france
on est appelés pour un forcené tue se
connaît la différence entre forces des
preneurs d'otages le forcené il est tout
seul et il menace de tout faire péter
non c'est pas ça pas forcément tous
fermés mais comme son mois indique le
preneur d'otages a pris les otages le
forcené n'a jamais d'otages mais il peut
être là ce n'est pas ce qu'on nous
appelle c'est qu'il a ouai c'est qu'il a
fait et qui tirent sur tout le monde
voilà sinon on n'y va pas après ça reste
un mec qui fait la gueule celui-ci en
question était un peu con - et donc là
c'était un forcené dont qu'il n'avait
pas d'otage mais c'était un militaire et
il est artificiers donc connaissez aussi
bien l'exploit que nous et ils s'étaient
retranchés dans un dépôt de munitions 74
d'une mission dans deux mines de mines
antichars il avait relié ces 64 tonnes à
des détonateurs il avait mis des
détecteurs sensorielle sur la porte donc
s'ils ont touché la porte par sympathie
ça a explosé donc on arrive sur les
lieux et on évalue à peu près là la
déflagration c'était mortel dans un
rayon de 5 km et donc donc on essaie
d'évacuer un grand nombre il ajoute tour
parce que ça met du temps pour gagner du
temps jeu avant qu'il va se répéter je
vais jusqu'à sa porte pour négocier ce
dont j'ai peur cioni d'équidés que je
commence à parler j'ai par classe tout
péter pour le coup ça va être un peu dur
de lui cacher ton rôle il connaît aussi
un peu ces systèmes militaires menées
alors
justement j'avais vraiment une enquête
sur lui il avait revendu sa maison et
dans sa voiture et l'avait dispatcher
son argent tous ces enfants ont donc été
comme super déterminer assez parano
quand même parce qu'il avait des
exigences il avait donné une lettre
d'exigence en première exigence c'est
par le ministre de la défense j'avais
envie de défoncer sa porte on va
permettre la ministre en danger pour
faire gagner du temps jusqu'à là sa
porte en espérant que quand je vais
prendre contact avec lille mais qui
verse pas le fil rouge sur le blog le
bouton rouge et boum et puis et puis non
il me répond tout de suite une réponse
lui qui veut des exigences tout ça en
fin de compte il dans l'armée si tu
passe pas au grade supérieur tu es viré
et sa hiérarchie il avait confié que
c'est l'anarchie sa hiérarchie l'avait
bloqué dans l'avancement donc été arrive
à 47 ans il avait quitté pas passer au
grade d'adjudant-chef et donc a été
obligé de partir lui voit la nuit s'est
sentie oui pour lui c'était une
injustice en tout cas la justice
complètement une injustice port mais il
m'écoute on parle beaucoup donc j'avais
pris une couverture comme quelqu'un de
très important pour philippe parano donc
qui vous parle la cabane important mais
pas militaire parce qu'il a un problème
avec énergie et on avait retrouvé dans
le l'arbre généalogique pas l'air j'ai
un défi dans l'organigramme militaire il
y avait un seul civil qui faisait qui
faisait partie du ministère de la
défense mais qui n'est pas militaire
donc j'ai pris sa couverture et donc
j'ai des jeux présente ah oui je sais
qui vous êtes et donc ça ça l'avait
rassuré et la première chose qui me
demande c'est de retirer son dossier
disciplinaire de l'armée pour le mettre
dans le civil démène pour lui j'y arrive
mais le problème c'est qu'un parano fait
pas confiance et donc il m'est toujours
en dotant d'autant doute et puis au bout
de deux jours on voit que ça n'avance
pas et là j'ai une idée je
jeudi temps d'appeler son avocat et son
avocat va venir et il va dire tout ce
que j'ai fait et ce que gêné de pathé je
sais quand son avocat il va avoir
confiance ssq a débloqué la faire quand
l'avocat dionysien oui il a réussi à
vous mettre le dossier disciplinaire
dans la ville riom civile là je voyais
que je les nie sa confiance que j'ai
gagné sa confiance est là on s'est
trompés parce qu'on pensait qu'il
voulait réintégrer l'armée ont dit voilà
il revenait forcément que j'aimerais
intégrer l'armée avec celle ému en fin
de compte c'était pas ça et en
communiquant avec lui c'est que j'ai
compris c'est qu'il voulait simplement
on reconnaisse qu'il avait été manipulé
par sa hiérarchie qu'il avait souffert
et il avait d'ores et déjà bien compris
quitté l'armée et tu vois une
information qu'on m'avait donné ses
textes qu'il voulait qu'on reste dans
l'armée donc c'est important de creuser
et en fin de compte ni c'était sûr et
certain et sailly moi j'ai quitté c'est
bon je m'en vais mais maintenant je veux
que je suis une victime je veux être
reconnu du harcèlement que j'ai reçu
c'est ce quick ce qu'ils voulaient en
fin de compte et ça colle encore avec ce
que tu disais un début de conversation
de ya souvent potentiellement une colère
ou une douleur ou une tristesse derrière
et si tu atteins passe sur ceux là tu
vas pas pouvoir régler le conflit si tu
restes trop en surface quand même et
donc au bout de trois jours il me dit ok
je sors et à chaque année sortez pas
comme ça je vais vous expliquer comment
vous allez sortir jeudi il ya des
indigènes qui sont là je suis pas que
lui qui gênent juni je lui explique que
vous allez ouvrir la porte doucement
vous allez enlever votre été le c'était
le 4 décembre donc des froids mais
michelier vous êtes en chemise obligé à
montaut d'embauché ou sanglante où vous
sortez en chemise vous ouvrez bien les
mains parce qu'on sait jamais s'il ya un
détonateur alors il faut savoir si c'est
un détonateur à relâchement si tu lui
une balle et qui meurt voilà ça explose
ou appui au bout d'une heure il sort
donc c'est moi qui vais dire qu'il
l'attend je regarde mes mains je
remercie la part détonateur je relate
bien c'est à téléphoner ça mais a comme
les tireurs d'élite qui sont exempts d
les grosses lunettes ils l'ont aussi en
jouant au cas où ça se passe mal et et
puis je n'ai pas le brusquer donc
pendant aller à 5 minutes on discute
comme ça sur le panier jeu peut
l'observer plus ou moins que l'on puisse
plus observé que les jumelles et où sa
pige du suivi moi et puis voilà six ans
des opérations du gie l'hygiène mais il
avait quitté son dépôt de munitions avec
des toilettes thermique il avait au
moins c'est biro pas fait les phillies
et il en avait pour six mois mais par
contre trois jours oui donc toi c'est
vrai on parlait d' état de fatigue au
recrutement de voir la force
psychologique de quelqu'un c'est là
c'est exactement là on voit est ce que
est ce que des fois tu t'es surpris à
avoir une vraie compassion malgré l'acte
qu'ils aient commis on en a un petit peu
parlé mais tu parlais de rester dans la
zone neutre de l'empathie est ce que des
fois malgré toi tu délires hoceïma ima
absorbées ou est-ce que tu as toujours
réussi à garder à distance alors des
fois non parce que le mec non tu peux
pas avoir d' empathie pour lui c'est
vraiment un gros sabots et puis des fois
oui des fois oui ou ses limites entre le
père de famille à saint amandois déjà à
partir du moment où tu te dis mince si
j'étais à sa place mais heureusement on
est toujours de négociateurs il ya le
négociateur principal qui communiquent
directement inclus prenantes âge il y en
a un deuxième qui observent le
négociateur et là il me met une main sur
l'épaule attention protège toi
psychologiquement parce que là tu vas
trop loin et elle ça me permet d'être
sûr d'avoir un oeil extérieur comme ça
ça permet de bien d'être recadré et
c'est super important ce qui dure aussi
des fois tu vois qu'un officier
coordinateur un officier coordinateur
lui il a un oeil sur le négociateur il
un oeil sur l'équipe d'assaut il a un
oeil sur les tireurs d'élite moi j'ai la
tête dans le guidon l'équipe ii reçoit
la tête dans le guidon et des tireurs
d'élite ont la tête dans le guidon et
c'est lui qui a managé tout ça est un
certain moment il peut me dire top nego
et même si je suis sur le c ur à jeter
les uns je les imagine vraiment faire à
l'asile vous êtes ouais alors bernard
tapie à gauche
mais là c'est un peu nigaud quand même
ses stocks négo oui et là il me dit
pendant que ça fait cinq heures gigou
silly stuff nego et bien je peux
t'assurer que des fois c'est frustrant
mais j'ai envie de m'en aller 5 minutes
fait d'avoir encore cette manne en
sinistres négoce et qu' il ya le liquide
d'assaut des données par la peur
exactement et pour pas me parasites et
une baie donne pas toi mais je sais
qu'il ya quelqu'un qui a une opportunité
ça m'est déjà arrivé sur l'émission stop
négo l'équipe d'assaut essayé de
l'attrapper main ça marche pas il se
retranche on repart sans la ligue 1 0 et
là c'est super dur là parce que me je ne
connais pas ses jambes je ne sais pas
qui va pas mentir pour monter un faux il
faut dire allah dans la vérité et quand
le preneur d'otages par exemple ne
souhaite pas parler alors il ya
plusieurs cas moi ça m'est arrivé
plusieurs fois trop pop a énormément
peut-être quatre fois ce sont des gens
qui en avait un qui était un schizo qui
voulait pas absolument pas du tout
rentrer dans la communication et puis
les deux autres hits qui est carrément
dans le mutisme ils n'ont jamais voulu
parler et donc à partir de là et qu
est-ce qui n'avait plus qu'un assaut a
donné voilà donc ce qui est l avantage
quand les négociateurs c'est que quand
et galasso est mature mais ta
combinaison et qui aura dans la colonne
d'assaut et qui est vague qui lancent
l'assaut avec tout le monde tut tut tut
l'a jamais ce côté opérationnel oui
c'est à dire que le lundi si on a besoin
de toi la négo omaterra négo mais si le
marvin à une intervention qu'on n'a pas
besoin des goûts maintenant alcon
d'assaut des jeux pas sûr que j'en ai
conscience de ça l on pense donc
exactement 10 on a trouvé ce système là
je crois qu'on est la seule habilitée à
le faire pourquoi parce que quand moi je
négocie pendant 15 heures l'équipe
d'assaut c'est que je sais ce qu'ils
ressentent web parce que demain je serai
avec eux et ça permet d'avoir un super
mais avec que douala s'était entendu
dire où je les lui je sais plus mais je
tiens ça de toi tu as dit ou écrit un
terroriste mort et plus puissante un
terroriste vivant donc c'est très très
fort comme discours du coup j'aimerais
bien que tu t'es tire un peu plus cette
pensée même si je pense avoir compris
mais des tellement impactante en fin de
compte ils se battent pour une idéologie
et donc ces gens là on va parler du
terrorisme islamiste qui complètement
différent que du terrorisme corse ou le
t elle
basque d'autres théories stories islam
is on a eu beaucoup de problèmes avec
eux pourquoi parceque ils se battent
pour mourir là par terre d'allah est
pour négocier il faut avoir quelque
chose là tu peux plus et donc ce qu on
avait remarqué c'est qu'ils agissaient
en trois phases il ya une première une
phase de tueries par le bataclan charlie
hebdo et puis après il ya une phase de
retranchement là ils peuvent prendre un
otage peut-être deux pas plus parce
qu'ils veulent pas trop s'embêter avec
les otages mais ils savent que c'est un
impact chez nous on arrive mme hasina
nos pains otage on va essayer de sauver
et en fin de compte c'est cette phase de
retranchements après la phase de tueries
ils s'en servent pour faire de la pub
lycée se faire de la publicité les
médias braizat et et puis au bout de
peut-être cinq six heures et ils ont
fait la une des chaînes et eu leur
dernière de l'otage et ils lancent
l'assaut contre les forces de l'ordre
pour mourir en martyr s'ils arrivent à
vous répartir il son martyre et voilà et
donc à partir de là ma forcément ça
soulève d'autres vocations parce que des
jeunes dans le veulent leur semble et en
plus ils ont comme une sépulture donc
c'était dieu de recueil aussi pour pour
des adapteurs elle mais ce que toi il
sera un autre domaine par exemple j'ai
passé déjà vu par un peu un français qui
se fait prendre en otage dans un pays
étranger et le pays demandera les
touristes demandent une rançon à la
france et ça dure des mois et des mois
et des mois des fois des années avant de
se mettre d'accord et là des familles
qui ont leurs enfants qui est pris en
otage dans un pays étranger qu'est ce
qu'ils font une marche blanche et le
problème faisant ça ils desservent là on
est sur du rationnel donc émettre de
l'émotionnel et les tours est ce que si
en fin de compte vous chers à notre et
donc il augmente le prix et l'état
français mais il s'en sort pas donc dans
ces cas là il faut faire confiance à
l'état mais aussi faudrait que l'état
communique mieux avec les familles en
disant on vous oublie pas on est là on
entre à négocier parce que s'ils se
sentent délaissés mais qu'est ce qu'ils
font ils montrent qu'ils sont oubliés et
là c'est catastrophique du coup ça pose
la question de la méthode de la
médiatisation que je me suis posé
beaucoup de fois et je pense que tout le
monde se la pose de ces camps quand on
voit des choses à la télé sur des prises
d'otages mais là ils disent tous ça et
10 qui intervient à ce qu'est ce que
c'est pas trop médiatisé ce qu'il
faudrait pas est ce que pour le droit à
la communication
ma foi ça ne devient pas du spectacle et
qu'il faudrait pas mais au contraire un
peu garder les choses en interne tant
que c'est pas réglé quoi c'est on va
dire en intervention des fois les
journalistes me posent des problèmes
parce qu'il donne les révèle des choses
il ne filme donc s'ils regardent la télé
savent déjà tout après nous on peut s'en
servir aussi journaliste hand on peut
oublier les a fuis voilà exactement en
général si on communique bien avec eux
ils sont quand même relativement sympa
voilà si on leur fait prendre conscience
que si on est en fin de course et c'est
comme tout il faut les désaccords
prudent le dispositif voilà alors nous
on va vous donner les informations mais
ne les envoie pas trop vite et à partir
de là mais ils sont contents ils ont
leurs informations et ils vont pas nous
parasiter la scène donc c'est important
de ne pas se les exclure nos contraintes
d inclure pour pouvoir les maîtriser
alors que si tu les exclus ben qu'il
maîtrise plus alors imagine un peu tard
et en mission tu as le préfet qui te dit
lancé un assaut moi je veux vite que ça
se termine négocier porta les
journalistes qui te disent n'ouvrez de
l'information parce qu'on veut que ça se
sache au niveau national tu as le maire
qu'est la clim surtout on n'est pas
d'informations parce que je fasse ma
commune soit entachée par cette prise
d'otages dans la famille des otages qui
te disent sauvez second bébé dans la
famille du preneur d'otages qui des fois
qu'il un kilo mais c'est pas un mauvais
bougre faut sauver et puis tu apprenants
de tâches qui veut qu'on satisfaire ses
revendications
mais voilà il faut que tu joues avec
tout ça que tu écoutes parce que c'est
super important tout ce que ces gens te
disent que tu te fasses une idée et puis
qu'après tu trouve les bons mots pour
négocier ton pendant d'otages aurait
donc gros travail ah oui ça c'est pas
après l'attentât de l'hyper cacher avec
deux stratégies des frères cauchy qui
s'était donc retranché dans une
imprimerie tu avais dit que c'était une
stratégie pour couvrir l'attentât à
paris la priorité avait vu juste puisque
les théories c'était en fait
synchronisée depuis le départ c'était
logique enfin c'était logique c'est ça
la question est-ce que c'était logique
pour toi directement grâce à ta ta
capacité d'analysé en tant que
négociateur à ce que tu l'as dit ça très
tôt ça s'est confirmé après ces quads
qui t'a permis de déjà de d'avoir cette
hypothèse mais surtout d'avoir c'est une
hypothèse assez forte pour la lancer et
pour l'affirmer comme ça je crois que
l'annoncé bien deux heures avant que le
je pense qu'ils essaient de gagner le
temps pour peut-être qu'ils aient
d'autres personnes qui lancent un autre
attentat par une sur paris et la
faudrait envoyer d'autres forces de
l'ordre de l'autre côté peut-être 7 10
aux tirs et les les forces de l'ordre
[Musique]
bernard tellier je rappelle vous êtes
sur notre plateau vous êtes un ancien
négociateur vous découvrez ce qui était
en train à ce qui est en train de se
passer c'est assez effarant parce qu'au
début de ce journal alors que cette
opération n'était pas en cours vous
l'avez quasiment décrite avant qu'elle
ne se produise mais c'est là où
l'intuition est énorme moi je vois des
gens qui critiquent l'intuition ben je
pense que ces gens qui critiquent
critique l'intuition n'ont pas de
connaissances terrain n'ont pas
d'expérience l'intuition c'est des
connaissances plus expérience mais si
t'as pas ces deux là qui veut pas voir
cette intuition et donc moi toutes les
prises d'otage que j'ai fait en fin de
compte c'est serge schéma tactique une
prise d'otages et il ya des signes que
tu
qu'ils sont inconscients mais que tu
ressens et tu peux pas l'expliquer
pourquoi mais un certain moment je le
savais pas renoncer ça en direct sur
france 2 sur inferno et à l'air bête et
je le savais il y avait tellement de
scie qui monte pour moi qui était
flagrant kylie qui est d'avoir une
deuxième prise d'otages il y avait un
manquement de cohérence sûrement par
rapport à ce que tu connaissais qui te
quitte armes dessus tu parles de
l'intuition l'intuition au niveau
rationnel c'est effectivement la somme
des connaissances et des expériences
qu'ils font quand même un agglomérat
énorme d'informations et de connexions
synaptiques qui font qu'à un moment
donné ton cerveau a pas le temps de
t'envoyer toute sa rationalisation des
hypothèses mais il était dit par rapport
à tout ce qu'on a vécu moi j'ai comparé
parce que le cerveau et associatif
comparative donc j'ai comparé quand même
chose et andré c'est un peu ça d'écouter
cette intuition non pas irrationnel mais
que je sais être rationnel mais qui va
un peu plus vite que ma pensée
consciente parfois quoi c'est un peu ça
et tu vois on chercher beaucoup de gens
comme ça au gign qui était intuitif
créatif et on veut pas de deux
militaires pure et dure aux jeunes qui
sont quittes rocard et voilà parce que
si tu es trop car il a osé prendre des
risques va pas osé aller au delà de
certaines choses on a un peu parlé mais
on n'est pas entré en profondeur de l'an
est ce que tu as déjà eu peur pour ta
propre vie pour ma propre vie à chaque
mission des premiers de la colonne
d'assaut 10 secondes avant de rentrer ta
peur et tu as peur parce que tu dis est
ce que et puis tu peux me fait peur à
tous peu à peu même te faire perdre
perdre
confiance en toi est-ce que je vais à la
hauteur est-ce que je vais réussir à
amener la groupe derrière moi pour
entrer dans l'appartement est-ce que
j'ai pas flanché à ce que j'ai pas
trouvé une balle et là ça cogite
acolytes mais ce qui est bien c'est que
l'action remplace la peur voilà dès que
le top action est parti ça y est bart
est dans l'action et a pris peur et donc
est ce que j'ai déjà eu peur en mission
plus que d'autres ouais je me suis fait
prendre en otage une fois alors c'est un
peu bizarre comme comme négociations
c'était une personne qui avait tué des
gens un couple est resté une petite
fille depuis qu'elle a atteint 8 10 ans
je rentre communication avec lui et je
parle pendant une heure là au téléphone
parce que quand je parlais à la voix il
m'a pas parlé du tout donc je recule un
peu je prends le téléphone du même
répond téléphone on parle pendant une
heure deux heures puis j'entends la
petite qui pleurent derrière puis il
s'est énervé sur la petite commence à me
crier dessus je suis dit écoute parce
que si on se tutoyait ou d'un monstre
toi ou je lis beaucoup de jean-pierre
mas que je te propose c'est que tu libé
relatif que je vienne à sa place il dit
ok à aucun moment je à la salle de la
spa ce qu'il avait comme tué et deux
gendarmes déjà et puis il avait tué le
couple mais c'était pour le faire sortir
de chez lui alors je dis moi coûte -
jean-pierre j'ai un peu peur j'écoute un
fusil jette ton fusil serait captivité
puis en échange il dit ok c'est vrai je
vois le fusil qui passe par la fenêtre
et puis je la porte qui sourd qui il il
passe sa main mais seulement joie que sa
main puis la plaque titre qui tient par
les cheveux donc j'avance un peu pas
trop près parce qu'on peut avoir une
deuxième arme et judy écoute approche
encore est effectivement là il sort et
je m'avance je vois l'équipe d'assaut
qu'il fonce dessus jette la petite par
terre il rentre chez lui des équipes
d'aso arrive à bloquer avec son pied
pousse la porte et rentrer à l'intérieur
moi je récupère cette petite qui a
allongé par terre en pleurs c'est ce que
j'entends crier dans l'appartenance des
maisons de cris dans la maison mais
c'est pas des cris de douleur parce que
quand l'équipe d'assaut attrapé la gale
ça c'est une mêlée de rugby un le gars
il est projeté il a mal mais là c'est
pas des cris de douleur ses écrits de
haine donc je donne la petite aux
pompiers et je rentre vite dans cette
maison qui est immense d'ailleurs et là
je m'aperçois que rien n'est fini que
tout commence en fin de compte il avait
un pistolet automatique ont été mis
juste en dessous du menton s'ils avaient
braqué avec invesco liquidation aurait
continué elle il leur a parlé mais il a
été plus malin et je les vois de m de
l'ofce arrive moi je suis à droite jean
je m'étais fait passer pour un médiateur
de la préfecture et là j'entends cris je
veux par le médiateur immédiatement et
j'ai rien à la maison gibert monsieur
durand je suis là devant jean-pierre
chela enfin il me regarde même pas
réunies à 5 secondes pour faire sortir
tout le monde sinon je mets une balle
dans la tête 5 4 3 il compte aussi vite
que ça et là je lis et d'intox ou pas et
puis arrivé à un seuil auquel tout le
monde sort et là l'équipe d'assaut en
marche arrière reviennent dans le salon
où je suis donc ils sortent de la
cuisine vient dans le salon ils se
cachent derrière le mur et là je suis
regard jean-pierre j'essayais son parti
à baisser votre arme il manque deux mois
ils sont contre le mur enfin quand il y
avait des cadres derrière moi est le
reflet des casques way et je suis là oui
je sais la pj où ils sont là mais son
parti de la cuisine d'un mec qu'a pas
beaucoup je pus personnes de chez moi à
part toi et je lui dis mais pourquoi
voulait que je reste manie parce que
j'ai confiance en pas on a parlé je veux
que tu restes là je regarde le chef du
groupe mais quand tu le sens je dis bien
alors je me suis rangé bien rester avec
vous mais mon premier qu'on fait pas de
mal compris pas de maladie non toi je te
prends pas de mal j'ai besoin de parler
je veux que tu restes c'est nous le
promettait je reste l'équipe d'assaut
s'en va donc et m'asseoir sur le canapé
et lui y descend il va s'éteindre c'est
bizarre ce amélie par un mini palier il
descend 5,6 marché dans le salon il n'y
va t'asseoir dans le canapé je passe
dans le canapé la première chose qu'il
fait fermer la porte à double tour
d'entrée la séparation du moment
non il n'a pas mangé la clé mais il l'a
mis dans sa poche et quand il va
s'asseoir sur canapé jours les deux
cadavres des parents derrière donc la
saa le stress le monde là elle et puis
il a son arme qui est comme ça et puis
on parle alors j'ai algarve larmes
complètement il a fait tellement fort
que je
et puis on parle casse cou au bout d'une
heure il ya des choses qu il
qu'ils font passer d'ampleur et les
choses qui va un peu mieux et puis je me
rappelle mme et mr un gobelet en
plastique et il sort une bouteille en
plastique sous la table basse et puis se
sert un verre de vin et donc la
synchronisation gestuelle et
émotionnelle gym a coulé mois
jean-pierre dans le vin est ce que je
peux avoir doublé mais jette un gobelet
si son gobelet de l'abeille est encore
le vin peu cramé au fond c'est donc je
prends la bouteille je me sert un verre
de vin et puis quand il boit ben je bois
d'ailleurs fait l'expérience si tu vas
dans un bar avec des amis vous êtes 5
voilà tu prends un coup de weert on a au
moins de 3 cm voire même temps voilà et
ben quand il boit je bois il a même
sorti des cacahuètes puis on discute
comme ça et puis au bout du four mois
deux heures tu me lis la semu commande
une pizza parce que là c'est l'apéro
c'est vrai les quelques salles et des
cacahuètes salées et là je me dis qu'il
ya c'est bon je pense que donc j'ai
essayé de c'est qu'on y croiser les
jambes j'attendais un peu je croisais
légende quand il se penchait vers moi je
me penche vers l'est j'essaie d'avoir
approuvé les mêmes gestes que lui
personnellement je décroise les jambes
et la 5 secondes après qu'est ce qu'il
fait il décroise les jambes
synchronisation s'inverse et donc je
prends mon verre je bois up ou 5,6
secondes après pensons verre et bois
viella ses manches et là je me lève j'en
suis sûr que certains qui va se lever on
va sortir une arme nez dehors comme un
apéro dînatoire il va serrer la main là
je lui attraper et puis l'équipe
d'assaut d'aller dans les trois secondes
je sais qu'ils vont me tomber dessus et
donc je me lève et la pompe ça marche il
se lève malheureusement navès passe par
dessus mon pistolet automatique mais je
sais que c'est pas de quart d'heure
derrière moi mais tu peux pas le voir
mais quand je me tourner pour aller à la
porte et va le voir donc là je trouve
une stratégie qui est pas mal mais ça va
marcher je vais sûrement d'avoir des
cacahuètes cdd fluide truc de malade et
à jamais la baisse mais le problème
c'est que j'ai pas été bons c'est que je
devais tellement tracassé par cette arme
que j'ai changé sa vie ted est
synchronisé comme il est très sensible
il a vu que j'étais plus pareil et là
tout de suite à une amie le pistolet au
haut niveau de la tête maintenant il m'a
dit tourne toi donc il savait déjà rue
tourne toi et manille alors on a des
systèmes pour taper une arme et il faut
que l'on ne touche mais à distance au
départ il va rien faire et là j'ai
vraiment envie de prendre mon art et
puis mais c'est impossible il a perpère
ça même si je suis rapide que possible
je me tourne mais il est à l'aise cela
va laisser la monnaie devient furie il
me dit un s'applique une butée et
pilleurs et puis vraiment il rire
vraiment nerveux à semble même pas le
fêter une arme qui lui pose problème
c'est le fait que tu lui a menti sur le
fait d'être le médiateur exactement 1 et
la tâche et heures forcément tout seul
et puis l'équipe d'assaut et les copains
et plus rien et je ni comment je vais
faire pour sortir de là dedans et ça
c'est la deuxième erreur que je fais
c'est j'essaye de m'en sortir plutôt de
me concentrer sur lui de le ramener à la
raison puis j'essaie de m'en sortir que
ça va énerver d'enfants et là je recule
forcément j'ai peur donc lui il avance
mais si je recule c'est stratégique
parce qu'il ya une fenêtre et lui il
avance quand j'aurais pu aider quand il
arrive dans la fenêtre je m'arrête comme
ça j'ai mis des tireurs d'élite vous
mettre une balle dans la main et avec
néanmoins je vais m'en sortir
malheureusement on n'avait pas lu mais
des lumières et faisait trop sombre avec
le redécoupage vu ce qui se passait à
l'intérieur et là un certain moment je
sais pas pourquoi j je me mets je viens
je la terre gyms l'iran je vais pas vous
faire confiance je me sens mal je peux
pas vous faire confiance ou moumié
premier compris pas mal aidé à me dis
mais pourquoi tu me lis l'aï regardé
vont menacer et je vais me l'aviez
promis c'était la condition pour que ray
shero et j'ai de la chance parce que il
reste encore un peu d'humanité et je les
touche émotionnellement la main parce
que pendant 2 pendant quatre heures je
l'écouté je n'ai pas jugé là il a remis
son arme sur son menton et lui dit j'ai
besoin j'ai besoin d'un verre d'eau il
est parti chercher un verre d'eau
dernièrement il y avait chez les décès
et les grosses clefs en fer forgé ou
d'accrocher est là mais avec une peluche
prend la clé je la teste elle ouvre la
porte à l'équipe place aux entrées et la
caméra de nexans vient pas pu me rendre
à 700 double
comme tous les sens on arrive à la fin
de l'interview je te libérer un moment
donné et a bien négocié est-ce que tu
avais des rituels à chaque opération
pour pour mieux appréhender la situation
on tombe anxiété comme on a par exemple
des rituels avant de monter sur scène y
en a qui en ont moi personnellement
j'essaie d'en avoir quasiment aucun pour
pas être dépendant de ses rituels au cas
où un jour je puisse pas aller faire ou
les avoir tués alors mais c'est vrai
t'as raison vaut mieux pas voir de
rituels moi je vois pendre on revient on
regardait les cours 200 m il en france
leur médaille le jour où ils perdent
leurs médailles sont foutus intérêt la
confiance en soi c'est terminé donc moi
j'avais un rituel c'était s'était pas
d'objecter rien du tout c'était de la
visualisation positive et je me mettais
alors on est en laisse ou en dehors donc
j'ai pas d'endroit pour remettre je me
mettais dans ma voiture je n'ai trois
grandes inspirations pour souffler un
peu toi père se faire baisser la
pression et puis je fermais mes yeux et
j'imaginais la mission déjà avec le
preneur d'otages qui se rendaient
qui va la personne de baisser je faisais
de choses c'est que je demandais un
détail positif sur trois ans d'otages
parce qu'on est communicatif et puis
donc à ce qu'il avait une personne qui
l'aimé parce qu'il avait un chien est ce
qu il avait un enfant est ce qu il avait
une passion dans la vie et j'allais
faire toute la négociation commencé ma
négocions là dessus et puis je m'isolais
et je visualise est positive ça me
permet c'est ça me permettait d'être un
peu plus serein comme les sportifs qui
veulent accomplir un exploit enfin ils
se font leur visualisation avant ou
qu'est-ce que tu quels souvenirs tu
gardes cette expérience en tant que
négociateur du gign
un jour je fais une conférence certains
de la confiance je me dis qu'est-ce que
vous aurais aimé changé dans votre vie
je dis surtout rien rien parce que je
retrouve peur qu'on me présent soit pas
identiques tous mes erreurs mais échec
mais réussit fond ce que je suis
aujourd'hui quand je regarde mes mes dix
années aux gènes que des bons souvenirs
parce que j'ai sauvé des centaines de
personnes que j'aurais jamais pu sauver
autrement 1
c'est très valorisant parce que quand tu
mets ta vie en jeu tu es obligé
d'évoluer si tu n'évolue pas d'un tumeur
un certain moment donc mais preneurs
d'otages ont fait évoluer la cohésion au
gign a fait évoluer et puis
moi même en analysant tout ça j'ai pu
évoluer énormément je te cache pas que
là on a fait 1 % de ce qu'on pourrait
faire en vidéo ensemble on va quand même
s'arrêter là parce que je pense que la
vidéo elle va faire une amie et nerveux
d'art et demi on va pas on va pas couper
grand chose on va tous vous laisser tu
as participé aussi très gentiment à ma
première émission de télé que j'ai écrit
je produis qu'ils appellent la grande
expérience c'est top ça va merci moi
j'ai vu les images mais tu m'étonnes
vous vous allez les voir aussi des
images elles vont être diffusés dans pas
longtemps vous êtes toutes les infos
qu'ils apparaissent là vous l'achetez
avait fait venir pour parler du mensonge
et la cohérence du discours etc bon
c'était aussi passionnant que là donc je
pensais que c'était par poser de
questions dessus si vous voulez voir
bernard parler tout ça vous faudra
regarder l'émission notez le dans
l'agenda ni c'est de la télé c'est pas
internet mais ça marche aussi très très
bien et je mets tous les liens dans la
description de ce qui concerne le merci
fabien franchement j'ai adoré ce format
juste la discussion avec un gars qui a
une vie de dingue une expérience de
dengue et un recul sur ce qu'il a fait
que tu es folle merci beaucoup à bernard
tellier de cette prêter à ce dîner au
palais des glaces ça va être cool prenez
soin de vous et à très bientôt charles